job try to save as many people as we can
sometimes that doesn't mean everybody
but you don't give up
New York
Washington DC circle yeah
okay that's enough captain people are
afraid
that's why I'm here
we need be put in check whatever form
that takes I'm game I'm sorry Tony if I
see a situation pointed South can't
ignore it sometimes I wish I could
sometimes I want to punch you in your
perfect teeth
I know we're not perfect
but the safest hands are still our own
come
I was wrong about you the whole world
was wrong about you they're coming for
you
I'm not the one that needs to watch
their back this doesn't have to end in a
fight Tony
you just started a war
stay down fine don't worry I could do
this all day
all right I've run out of patience
underoos
hey everyone
hey youtubers it's Charlie they totally
did the thing spider-man is in the
Captain America civil war trailer so
let's break it down hey everyone how's
it going what's up odds were actually on
them not using spider-man at all but I
totally love the costume and they
animated his eyes
Deadpool style it's only a coincidence
that I actually put on my Deadpool shirt
this morning
so starting at the beginning of the
trailer what it looks like is going on
is that they either have Winter Soldier
in cold storage or this is where Hydra
is keeping him stored because it looks
like they're using him as proxy for
nitro in their version of the Stanford
incident in comic book Civil War nitro
ended up going nuclear and blowing up a
whole bunch of schoolchildren and a big
area of the suburbs so that's what's
happening later in the trailer with
Black Panther here so it seems like
that's what inspires him to go after
Winter Soldier so you see him chasing
him down you see cap getting caught in
the middle of it I love the fact that it
seems like they're running faster than
moving cars here when caps talking about
not being able to save everyone all the
time he's talking about collateral
damage
and that's why Thunderbolt Ross is
playing that phase one phase two
PowerPoint presentation aliens Hydra
Ultron Scarlet Witch throwing up in her
mouth just a little bit I love the way
cap looks at her and notices and tells
Thunderbolt Ross to shut it down just
like this is [ __ ] alright we've
heard enough
we understand Iron Man enters the
equation probably because of what
happened during Avengers age of Ultron
when Scarlet Witch gave him those
visions via the mind gem about this
future path of destruction that they
were on he's probably still reeling from
that he is textbook post-traumatic
stress so I'm guessing this awesome
undersea prison is stark tech I love the
editing here the safest hands are still
our own as Iron Man is putting his glove
on to stop winter soldiers bullet and
I'm wondering if Winter Soldier is
actually trying to kill Iron Man or if
Iron Man is just stepping between him
and his target he might be present for
this stamford incident the way they edit
the trailer makes it look like Bucky
shooting down war machine but this is a
giant energy blast that looks like it's
coming from visions mind gem and
technically this is happening during
their big IMAX sequence is this big 15
minute scene that I'm guessing because
spider-man is in it is going to be their
big third act battle so heartbreaking I
was wrong about you Iron Man's talking
to Captain America when he's saying that
the
world was wrong about you that's because
cap chooses his friend over what Ironman
thinks is right they set the movie up to
intentionally make you question who is
in the right because Ironman isn't wrong
Captain America isn't wrong depending on
whose perspective you take you're always
doing the right thing
Ironman is always going to think that
he's doing the right thing Captain
America is always going to try to do the
right thing they're just using Bucky to
put Captain America in opposition to
Ironman plus cap probably isn't too hot
about secret undersea prisons that
nobody knows about something feels
really sinister about that if you're
reading Marvel Comics right now shield
is actually using the Cosmic Cube to
rehabilitate prisoners they use the
tesseract to change their reality to
make them into different people and it's
like forced rehabilitation it's very
Clockwork Orange where they kind of
brainwash villains into being good but
it's all Maria hill when cap finds out
about it he's just like what the hell
have you been doing this is crap when
Ironman tells Black Widow they're coming
for you I wonder if this is happening
early in the film and he's talking about
actual villains or if this is later in
the film and he's talking about the
security council that they form like
they know about the red on your ledger
they're coming to make you atone for
that she is team Iron Man but Scarlett
Johansson explained that it's just
because she has so many reservations
about saving Bucky because the red and
his ledger is so much worse we got to
talk a little spider-man now the rumor
is is that this is actually in Aunt
May's apartment cap has his shield in
this so I'm wondering if this happens
before that big battle with spider-man
where he shows up spider-man is supposed
to start out on one team end up on the
other which is kind of how it goes down
in the comics in the comics he started
out team Iron Man then when Captain
America it might be the other way around
in this I'm really hoping that it
actually is comic-book civil war style
where he starts out with iron man he
gets some tech for his new spider suit
which it looks freakin badass I love the
way they animated his eyes so much then
has the moral dilemma and goes team cap
interesting scene here this is actually
taking place connected to that other
scene where we find Winter Soldier and
cryo storage so this might be happening
relatively early in the film but I can't
believe that they would come to blows so
quickly so this might be happening at
some other point I find it hard to
they would be fighting at the very
beginning of the film usually things go
from strained bad to worse to dead
looking people like Panther vs Winter
Soldier looking pretty freakin badass
there's some claw marks on cap shield
and some of the pictures that they've
shown it to so you have to remember that
Black Panthers suit is vibranium weave
just like we learned during Avengers age
of Ultron the most valuable substance on
earth and the humans use it to makeup
frisbee so you can actually make all
kinds of stuff with vibranium so imagine
a suit that's as strong as Iron Man's
but as lightweight is Captain America's
plus he has some pretty awesome
vibranium claws Scarlet Witch versus
vision looks like she's controlling him
and when you look in the background does
this not look like a giant Jenga puzzle
that maybe vision has been working on
this whole time
what are you been up to just pondering
the meaning of existence working on some
Jenga and then probably the other
biggest WTF scene in the trailer next to
spider-man they actually do the comic
book thing where ant-man rides on one of
Hawk man's arrows you can see he's
flying on to Iron Man's armor it looks
like they're trying to use him to
disable Iron Man Captain America versus
crossbones this is actually supposed to
happen relatively early in the film this
might be the final battle of the film
now I know I said the IMAX scene is that
big one on the tarmac supposed to be 15
minutes is going to be spectacular
this might be the actual last battle the
one where someone really does wind up
dead and I don't think they're gonna
kill Iron Man I think it's more likely
that they would go with comic books
Civil War I could do this all day where
have I heard that before and then we get
the splash page IMAX scene that I was
talking about let them fight alright
I've run out of patience the whip you
inked hey guys what's up this really
does look like he had some help from
Tony Stark designing it because he's
supposed to start out in this really low
fight teenage looking version of it I
just love how expressive his eyes are
they did that during Deadpool which is a
relatively new thing for comic book
movies the reason you do this is because
one it's just like the comics and you
can use his eyes the same way you would
use someone's face when he gets really
mad when he's happy when he's crying you
see it on the way his eyes change so
this is really interesting face
storytelling that's going on we haven't
seen before except in Deadpool Deadpool
is just the most recent example of a
movie that's try that because this looks
so awesome just expect them to do this
with more comic book movies where people
we're masks in the use animation to make
their eyes move so they don't have to
take their masks off so let me know in
the comments what you guys favorite
moment from this I'm going to take a
stab and say probably spider-man showing
up but if you didn't know daredevil
season 2 is dropping a week from Friday
I'll be doing videos just like it did
for Jessica Jones all the other
daredevil stuff I did during season 1 so
be sure to subscribe to get everything
there will be more Captain America Civil
War stuff just maybe one more really big
trailer a couple teasers and then the
week after daredevil drops we're going
to get Batman V Superman so [ __ ] is on I
am so excited for the next two or three
months in Game of Thrones is in there
too I know it's not Marvel related but
it's going to be freaking awesome
why you guys wait for my next video to
post you can click here for all my
Captain America Civil War videos and you
can click here for the Game of Thrones
red band trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you